figaro live il est presque 8h20 et
bonjour et bienvenue donc sur
lefigaro.fr et sur notre page youtube
nous sommes en direct nous sommes donc
le 2 septembre jour de la rentrée
scolaire et c'est la deuxième rentrée
depuis que le coït 19 est entré dans nos
vies alors à quoi va ressembler cette
horreur cette rentrée quel est le
nouveau protocole sanitaire qui
s'applique dans les écoles collèges et
lycées à partir d'aujourd'hui pour en
parler à côté de moi je suis avec hotbar
yéti bonjour bonjour aux vous êtes donc
journaliste au service société du figaro
en charge de l'éducation notamment et
sur le terrain nous sommes également en
direct avec maud ken hicks valdes qui
est journaliste au figaro étudiant et
qui se trouve devant un ensemble d'école
primaire du xviie arrondissement de la
capitale l'ensemble fourcroy laugier
mode canine val est ce que vous nous
entendez c'est à vous
rentrée a eu à voir parce que avec un
peu 2019 les rentrées se font en décalé
actuellement c'est l'excitation de se
retrouver entre copains ya les listes
qui sont affichés jusque devant l'école
et ça permet à un couple de savoir se
remettre dans une classe qu'on aime ou
pas donc les petits sont tous contents
de se retrouver ils portent à peu près
tous le masque ils sont généralement pas
réticent à le faire donc voilà donc pour
l'instant c'est la rentrée des cp et de
ce1 et on attend du coup les autres
places par vagues
merci mode on vous retrouve tout à
l'heure alors on va faire un petit point
justement sur ce protocole vous venez de
dire donc que les les élèves à partir de
6 ans désormais porter un masque alors
on veut faire un petit point ensemble en
plateau d'ailleurs si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas à les poser sur
lefigaro.fr et sur notre page youtube
nous y répondrons si nous avons bien sûr
la réponse sinon nous chercherons sur
internet si nous l'avons pas en mémoire
mais posez nous toutes vos questions sur
ce nouveau protocole sanitaire qui entre
en vigueur alors le ministère de
l'éducation a établi quatre niveaux de
progrès sanitaires pour cette rentrée
c'est donc le niveau 2 qui est appliquée
ryad bclear qui est à la réalisation va
pouvoir vous montrer donc ces quatre
protocoles en tout cas le visuel qui
avait été communiqué par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale alors on le voit
là en plein écran donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas très digeste voire illisibles
donc on est sur la tranche jaune c'est
ça absolument aude est-ce que vous
pouvez nous détailler un petit peu ce
protocole pas écouté déjà ce qu'il faut
retenir et ce qui est très important
c'est qu'il faut toujours bien respecté
les gestes barrières les gestes barrière
le lavage de mains évidemment le port du
masque en intérieur l'aération des
salles le respect de la distanciation
quand c'est possible donc ça il faut
vraiment toujours faire bien attention à
cela et ensuite jean michel blanquer a
en effet annoncé que c'était le
protocole de niveau 2 qui avait été
choisi ça implique plusieurs règles
notamment le port du masque en intérieur
pour tous en revanche en extérieur les
enfants pourront enlever le masque à
moins que le préfet les autorités
locales et décider d'une obligation du
port du masque en extérieur ça peut
arriver dans plusieurs communes
plusieurs villes notamment celles qui
sont soumises à une forte recrudescence
du virus il faut pas oublier qu'en cette
rentrée 2021 certes on est un petit peu
habitué maintenant au co vide c'est déjà
la deuxième rentrée scolaire sous
qu'ovide mais on doit faire face aux
variantes delta qui est beaucoup plus
contagieux quant à l'union est donc là
dessus il faut faire particulièrement
attention alors justement est-ce que des
mesures spécifiques sont mises en place
pour le variant delta ou pas du tout ce
qu'il ya des d une
distanciation social un peu plus
importantes entre les élèves ou des
moments de brassage qui sont évités
contrairement à l'année dernière où dit
on va dire que ce marin d'état ne
l'était été moins prégnant on va dire
l'année dernière est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui ont été modifiés on va dire
alors tout a beaucoup évolué depuis
l'année dernière évidemment le
il faut toujours faire attention quand
même dans la mesure du possible à
respecter a essayé d'éviter le brassage
entre élèves donc il faut essayer de
rester plutôt par groupe que ce soit par
classe par niveau alors évidemment il ya
des différences en fonction des âges
c'est à dire que vous pouvez pas
demander à un élève de maternelle de
respecter autant la distanciation
non brassage que un élève de lycée qui
sera plus grand donc par exemple il ya
déjà des temps scolaires qui sont moins
évidentes d'autres la récréation je
pense notamment à la récréation s'il n'y
a pas de port de masques il n'ya pas non
plus de distanciation il enfants jouent
ensemble dans la cour c'est important
que les enfants jouent que les enfants
respirent se voit c'est aussi ça l'école
et c'est bien et au mode l'a dit tout à
l'heure ils sont contents de se
retrouver mais il n'y a pas tellement de
distanciation possible en cours de
récréation par exemple une autre des
grandes questions c'est la cantine qui a
été décrite par plusieurs acteurs de
l'éducation nationale qu'on a rencontrés
là pendant ces derniers jours comme un
véritable angle mort un trou dans la
raquette parce que évidemment de fait à
la cantine on ne peut pas porter masque
en mange j'ai donc c'est plus compliqué
de faire très attention donc pour ça les
établissements scolaires ont mis en
place différentes choses il y en a qui
font des jeunes et les élèves en
quinconce il y en a qui on est large et
aussi un petit peu leur horaire pour
éviter que les élèves se croisent y en a
qui mobilise deux nouvelles salles les
établissements s'adaptent le mieux
possible à sauver le coup est ce que les
services de restauration collective sont
de nouveau actifs en cette rentrée parce
que bon c'est vrai qu'il ya une époque
où l'on conseillé
de faire les petits plats et que chacun
- jeu sur sa table etc les plats
préparés par les parents des choses
comme ça alors oui le rassure les
parents de la cantine sera bien ouverte
si vous avez inscrit votre enfant votre
enfant ira à la cantine après évidemment
ce sera un petit peu différent notamment
le ministère préconise de 2
de plutôt faire du service individuel il
faudrait aussi dans en théorie éviter le
vrac voilà plongé sa main dans 20 dans
une bague de pain tout ça c'est des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut plus faire
mais les collectivités locales les
écoles sont maintenant habitués donc
voila apres ya certains établissements
qui peuvent mettre en place des choses
de particulière par exemple hier j'étais
un reportage au centre jeanne élisabeth
et là ils ont décidé un jour par semaine
pour certains élèves de faire une lunch
box donc en effet c'est un petit repas
remporter mais l'idée ce n'est pas de le
faire tous les jours donc je rassure les
parents il y aura bien un service de
restauration à la scolaire si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes donc en direct en
direct pour ce 2 septembre pour cette
deuxième rentrée scolaire placée sous le
signe du coc vide une rentrée qui se
veut un petit peu plus à la normale on
est seulement au niveau 2 de scénario on
va dire envisagée par l'éducation
nationale sur le protocole sanitaire
dont code-barres yéti qui est
journaliste au service société en charge
des questions d'éducation notamment est
là pour répondre à toutes vos questions
sur ce protocole sanitaire je vous avoue
qu'il ya beaucoup de parents d'élèves
mais aussi d'enfants également des
journalistes ou des gens qui sont pas de
la profession mais qui se posent des
questions sur ce protocole sanitaire
c'est quand même assez flou je vous
invite à vérifier donc tous les
informations sur les papiers du figaro
et notamment toutes les informations qui
sont données par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale mais nous sommes
là en direct pour répondre à vos
questions alors n'hésitez pas à les
poser sur les tchats du figaro.fr moi
j'ai une petite question concernant la
vaccination
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas mal de
commentaires sur certains de nos
articles sur le figaro.fr qui qui
suggéré l'idée qu'il y aurait une
discrimination on va dire entre les
élèves non vaccinés et les élèves
vaccinés est ce que c'est le cas en
cette rentrée alors je pense que déjà
l'essentiel c'est vraiment de rappeler
qu'il n'ya pas de passes sanitaires à
l'école il n'y a pas de passe à lithaire
à l'école donc votre enfant peut venir à
l'école qu'ils soient vaccinées ou non
vacciner déjà je pense que ça c'est
vraiment important de le rappeler
puisque la vaccination n'est pas
obligatoire pas pour pas pour les
enfants en tout cas
en revanche il ya eu une ou deux
situations dans laquelle la non
vaccination pourrait poser problème la
première c'est en cas de contact faire
en cas de contamination d'un
un jeune dans une classe de collège
lycée la règle c'est ouf et une sorte d'
enquête pour déterminer qui sont les
quatre contact de cet élève et ensuite
où on regarde si c'est qu'à contacter la
sont vaccinés ils peuvent retourner en
cours sans problème en revanche s'ils ne
sont pas vaccinés il faut qu'il s'isole
chez eux pendant sept jours donc ça
c'est une mesure qui a fait beaucoup
parler parce que les syndicats certains
parents plusieurs acteurs du monde de
l'éducation nationale craignent que ça
fasse vraiment une sorte de l'éducation
à deux vitesses entre les enfants qui
sont vaccinés et ceux qui ne le sont pas
et ensuite la deuxième problématique qui
risque de se poser c'est pendant les
sorties scolaires pendant les sorties
scolaires si vous allez dans un endroit
où il ya un créneau réservé aux élèves
il aura pas de passe sanitaire parce
qu'on considère que c'est finalement du
milieu scolaire donc par exemple vous
allez à la piscine avec uniquement votre
classe pas besoin de ta sanitaire mais
vous allez au théâtre ou dans un musée
et là il ya d'autres personnes qui sont
avec vous il faudra le pass sanitaires
alors je rappelle que le pass annie
terre c'est pas obligatoirement la
vaccination l'enfant peut aussi se faire
tester mais il adviendra un jour au à
l'automne où les tests deviendront
payants est donc là la question se
posera d'ailleurs jean-michel blanquer a
été interrogé sur ce sujet sur la
question très précise de la gratuité des
tests notamment en milieu scolaire et il
a dit que c'est c'est une question à
laquelle il répondrait dans les semaines
à venir ce que ça suscite évidemment
beaucoup d'interrogations est-ce qu'il
faudra payer pour avoir des tests à
l'école on pense plutôt que non mais
jean michel blanquer radi qui
préciserait tout ça dans les prochaines
semaines merci aux deux vous avez parlé
du coup de l'isolément on va dire pour
les personnes qui contactent non
vaccinés évidemment pour les élèves de
plus de 12 ans parce qu'avant il n'y a
pas de vaccination qu'est ce qui se
passe pour les élèves avant 12 ans du
coup si aucun contact s'il ya une
personne positive on va dire dans une
classe et donc plusieurs élèves qui
l'ont côtoyé qui sont qu'à contacter
alors la règle or en primaire c'est un
cas une fermeture donc là c'est pour
tout le monde qu'on soit actif dont on
ne peut pas être vaccinés en pré vert
donc c'est pour tout le monde le un
élève de primaire est positif la classe
ferme donc après les enfants seront
testés parce que quelque chose dont on
n'a pas encore parlé pour le moment et
qui est très important c'est évidemment
la stratégie du dépistage jean michel
branquart a annoncé un objectif assez
ambitieux de 600 mille tests par semaine
que ce soit des campagnes cible et parce
qu'on a des on a des soupçons parce
qu'il ya des cas qui commencent à se
multiplier dans un établissement ou
alors dd campagne plus large mais en
tout cas les enfants s'ils disposent
d'une autorisation parentale seront
souvent tester alors je rassure quand
même tout de suite les parents et
peut-être les jeunes qui nous écoutent
pour les plus jeunes ce sera plutôt des
tests salivaires donc plutôt indolore
par rapport aux tests auxquels nous nous
sommes habitués par l'onu
merci aux deux si vous nous rejoignez
nous sommes donc toujours en direct sur
lefigaro.fr et sur la page youtube du
figaro la page figaro live merci de nous
suivre en direct en ce jour de rentrée
donc plus de 12 millions d'élèves
retrouver les bancs de l'école
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs nous allons
retrouver tout de suite en direct mode
phoenix valdes journaliste au figaro
étudiant qui se trouve devant une école
primaire enfin un ensemble d'école
primaire du xviie arrondissement mode
c'est à vous
de joueurs en fait de se retrouver pour
la plupart en fait la formation actuelle
c'est se retrouver ensemble pour
profiter un petit peu entre copains au
niveau des les balles sont plus
forcément respectée parce qu'ils ont
tous envie de se faire des câlins de
pouvoir retrouver un petit peu la
proximité est justement par rapport aux
masques c'est encore une fois pas
quelque chose qui redoute forcément ils
me disent que je ne pose pas de problème
de le porter
c'est un peu le prix à payer pouvoir
continuer ensemble et en bonne santé
c'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit après
actuellement leur continuation c'est
plutôt leur professeur savoir si jamais
il va être gentil avec eux si jamais les
bras de l'enseignant qui ont pas trop
laisser c'est à ça que j'ai ressenti
c'est un petit peu le stress ou
hilarants très médiocre et finalement tu
sembles à peu près normale pour tous
merci merci mode une rentrée normale
aude qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors
que c'est ce qu'il ya d'anormal dans
cette rentrée comme disons que c'est le
voeu de jean michel blanquer le miso
éducation nationale il a dit qu'il
espérait une rentrée la plus normale
possible après est ce qu'on peut parler
de rentrée normale nous toutes les
personnes qu'on a interrogés ici et là
je parle évidemment pas d'une entrée
normale mots de parlais à l'instant du
masque alors oui tout le monde fait avec
le masque mais on a quand même plusieurs
personnes qui sont revenus nous voir en
disant que c'était vraiment très pénible
les professeurs qui le portent pendant
des heures d'affilée tout en devant
dispenser leurs cours on avait un
professeur d'anglais notamment une
professeur d'anglais qui nous expliquait
que pour la prononciation de ses élèves
s'étaient particulièrement difficile
voilà il ya le masque la distanciation
le nom brassage l'aération des salles
certaines règles on en parlera
probablement doute à l'heure certaines
règles quand même en eps certaines
problématiques pour la cantine voilà on
peut pas on peut pas parler d'une
rentrée 100% normal en revanche ce que
les professeurs les directeurs nous
disent c'est qu'ils bénéficient quand
même de 18 mois d'expérience 18 mois de
recul sur cette crise decaux vide et que
même si les protocoles change
régulièrement ce qui est
particulièrement difficile pour eux en
fait ils ont acquis des leçons ils ont
acquis de l'expérience qu'ils peuvent
réutiliser aujourd'hui et ça c'est vrai
que c'est quand même un atout et puis
évidemment atout supplémentaire par
rapport à la rentrée dernière et toute
l'année dernière c'est la vaccination
est ce que vous savez si les profs ou
les syndicats de professeurs ont été
consultés et écoutés on va dire pour la
mise en place de ces protocoles alors il
ya eu des réunions notamment l'a
récemment mais c'est vrai que
on a senti que les syndicats là qu'ils
ont tenue très récemment leur conférence
de presse de rentrée n'était pas
satisfait de ce protocole ils ont jugé
pour plusieurs insuffisant inquiétant et
notamment ce qu'il reproche au ministère
c'est d'avoir choisi de d'harmoniser le
protocole 2 sur tout le territoire
métropolitain elle en profite pour
rappeler qu en outre-mer peut-être on en
parlera tout à l'heure la situation est
très différente mais donc pour l'instant
ces protocoles 2 sur tout le territoire
évidemment les situations sont pas les
mêmes dans tous les territoires dont
dans tous les territoires dont plusieurs
personnes sont un peu interrogatif
donc toute la question sera de voir ce
qui se passe pendant les premières
semaines et jean michel blanquer a bien
insisté sur le fait que le protocole
pourrait être amené à évoluer soit à
diminuer en intensité soit à se
renforcer si la situation empire et ça
pourra aussi être distingué en fonction
des territoires donc si on sent que dans
un territoire il ya une situation
particulièrement compliqué le protocole
pourra évoluer là alors qu'il n'évoluera
pas dans la région voisine donc tout ça
il faudra vraiment voir comment la
rentrée se passe aujourd'hui c'est le
premier jour et il faudra voir dans les
prochaines semaines comment la situation
évolue est ce qu'ils ont déjà mis en
place des critères on va dire pour dire
à partir de temps de classe fermée dans
tel département on passe au niveau 3 ou
sais pas encore alors il ya plusieurs
critères en effet pour pour déterminer
ce protocole notamment je pense aux taux
d'incidence au taux de vaccination et
puis en fait les les autorités locales
auront aussi leur mot à dire donc ça
c'est important qu'on voit que
évidemment le rôle des autorités locales
est toujours très important je parlais
notamment du port de
de la règle du port du masque en
extérieur elle s'impose au milieu
scolaire quand le préfet a décidé
qu'elle s'imposait à toute cette zone
donc le billet scolaire n'est pas n'est
pas complètement exclu de toutes ces
problématiques alors on va revenir
justement dans le détail dont vous avez
parlé du port du masque odm et on va
revenir justement sur sur les courts de
ps est ce que c'est possible de
pratiquer du basket en salle cette année
alors le ps est vraiment une des
priorités de l'année en tout cas ça a
été annoncé comme tel par le ministère
ce qu'on a bien vu que pour les enfants
c'était vraiment particulièrement pour
les enfants les jeunes c'est vraiment
particulièrement important donc la règle
normalement c'est plutôt le ps en
extérieur mais dans le protocole de
niveau 2 on peut faire du sport à
l'intérieur en revanche les sports de
contact sont détruites n'ont pas de
bottes papa de boxe pas de but même par
exemple un sport qui est très en vogue
au collège pas d'accroc sport donc pour
ça les professeurs doivent s'adapter
nous les professeurs de sport qu'on a
rencontrés nous disent que voilà il
maintenant ils savent faire il ya quand
même plus de choses qui peuvent faire
maintenant qu'à une certaine période
donc ils vont essayer de faire un
maximum d'activités en extérieur
notamment en ce moment puisque puisque
le temps le permet et puis ensuite s'il
faut passer en intérieur on passera en
intérieur mais pas de sport de contact
et pour la cantine alors est ce que on
peut expliquer un petit peu en détail
tout ce qui va se passer pour la cantine
alors la cantine comme je le disais tout
à l'heure c'est quand même une des
grandes critiques qui est fait à ce
protocole de niveau 2 nous on a
plusieurs personnes qui sont venues nous
voir enfin nous expliquer en interview
en fait elle aurait aimé que le
protocole soit peut-être le même partout
sauf sur certaines choses comme la
cantine avec un niveau de protocoles
plus contraignant parce qu'aujourd'hui à
la cantine il ya des grandes
recommandations mais il n'y a pas de
règle vraiment très très contraignante
donc il recommandait que les élèves
déjeunent à la même table notamment en
premier cycle il est recommandé qui ne
se mélangent pas il est recommandé
d'éviter le vrac d'éviter le 22
c'est plutôt privilégier le service à
l'assiette des choses comme ça mais
ensuite c'est les établissements
scolaires qui doivent s'adapter donc en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
comme il y en a qui bénéficie de tout le
monde bénéficie 18 mois d'expérience et
certains en fait ont adopté des règles
qui vont peut-être gardé par exemple on
a plusieurs plusieurs établissements qui
nous ont fait savoir que c'était
intéressant pour eux de faire déjeuner
les élèves en groupe deux classes de
niveau parce que ça fluidifier le
système donc ça peut être que ça va
continuer et d'ailleurs ça c'est un peu
être un aspect positif finalement de
toute cette crise qui touche évidemment
le milieu scolaire c'est qu'il ya des
enseignements qui vont rester quand
j'étais en reportage
sainte-jeanne-élisabeth dans le 7e hier
vous m'expliquer que maintenant il y
avait des entrées un peu différenciés en
fonction des groupes les 6e 5e à un
endroit 4e 3e arr nôtre et que c'est un
système qui marchait bien donc peut-être
qu'ils allaient perdurer après la après
la crise du covin donc ça c'est
intéressant et c'est le peut-être le
point positif qu'on peut tirer de cette
crise c'est qu'il ya des adaptations de
l'école parfois contrainte et forcée on
sera contents de les abandonner et
parfois pour le meilleur notamment en
termes de pratiques pédagogiques
merci aude le chat de notre page youtube
vient d'où vient donc juste d'être
rétabli merci à adrien brillant être
juriste social media il y avait un petit
souci de chat donc désormais il est à
nouveau ouvert n'hésitez pas à poser
toutes vos questions le chat du
figaro.fr est toujours disponible nous
sommes donc en direct pour commenter et
vivre ensemble donc cette rentrée des
classes 2021 nous allons d'ailleurs tout
de suite retrouvé mode ken hicks balle
qui se trouve devant un ensemble d'école
primaire du xviie arrondissement mode
c'est avoué je crois que les élèves sont
entrés les
intéressés par étapes moi ce que je suis
peut-être scellé usd par an ce sac est
le plus important c'est que plus l'image
que celui de choses les enfants sont
cependant on peut venir qui sont plutôt
léger les parents ont un peu plus peur
ils redoutent même parfois le fait qu'il
est qu'elle puisse s'arrêter en cas
d'aggravation de la crise ça serait pas
produit pendant ce temps mais il le
redoute quand même et par rapport aux
enfants de la même manière il n'y aurait
pas assez rigoureux moi j'ai vu des
enfants se mettre du gel avant d'entrer
j'ai dû faire vérifier s'il avait accès
de base donc voilà on est plutôt sur des
gestes qui peuvent rassurer pour cette
rentrée
merci mode justement donc il ya une
angoisse des parents je pense que leur
angoisse principal c'est peut-être que
l'école ferme est-ce qu'on peut rappeler
aux deux bars yéti dans quelles
conditions une école ou une classe on va
dire du moins va fermer 7 connaît alors
une vraie différence entre le premier et
second degré en primaire en premier
degré s'il ya un cas toute la classe
ferme tout cas qu'à deux fermes et donc
pendant plusieurs jours et ensuite peut
revenir si la situation s'est améliorée
en revanche dans le second degré
collèges lycées si un cas confirmé dans
une classe mène une sorte d' enquête
autour de lui pour savoir qui sont ces
cas contacts à risque et ensuite là tout
dépend de son statut vaccinal si on est
vaccinés on peut rester en cours si on
n'est pas vaccinée on doit repartir chez
soi est ce que disait mot de tout à
l'heure et intéressant sur le fait que
l' angoisse des parents c'est de fermer
des classes des écoles c'est aussi
d'ailleurs l'angoissé professeur j'y
reviendrai dans un instant parce que les
parents évidemment s'ils se retrouvent
avec leurs enfants à la maison il faut
pouvoir s'en occuper donc là il se passe
ce qui s'est passé finalement l'an
dernier c'est que le gouvernement
l'exécutif a mis en place un système de
chômage partiel si les deux parents ne
peuvent pas télétravail et il y en a un
qui peut être mis en chômage partiel
pour s'occuper de son enfant
quant aux professeurs sans limite d'âge
c'est à dire même si votre enfant à 16
ans on peut bénéficier c'est une bonne
question c'est vrai que je vais arriver
désavoué dans le protocole pour les airs
du travail se met en effet en tout cas
un enfant qui a besoin d'être gardés
donc il faut évidemment des preuves il
faut montrer il faut prouver que l'école
de l'enfant est fermé ou qui les cas
contacts à risque mais en tout cas
normalement 1
un parent peut bénéficier du dispositif
du chômage partiel si son enfant ne peut
pas aller en cours et quant aux
professeurs c'est vrai qu'ils sont assez
angoissé parce que tout ce qu'on a
rencontrés nous disent que eux ce qu'ils
veulent c'est la classe c être face à
leurs élèves c'est que leurs élèves
puissent avoir cours c'est un impératif
d'égalité de justice sociale de
d'énormément de choses donc qu'ils
puissent être en cours donc il faut
vraiment très peur que ça doivent fermer
après le ministère est plutôt optimiste
pour l'instant et on a vu que dans
certains territoires ça se passait
plutôt bien par exemple à la réunion où
les élèves ont repris depuis le 17 août
je crois que c'est autour de 0 2% de
fermetures de classes après ça c'est la
réunion on sait que dans les territoires
d'outre-mer et des situations très
contrastées notamment on sait
qu'aujourd'hui les élèves martiniquais
guadeloupéens des antilles et de
certaines zones rouges de guyane ne
feront pas leur rentrer comme tous leurs
camarades il faudra attendre au minimum
jusqu'au 13 septembre parce que la
situation là bas est urgent est trop
difficile
qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer il me
vient une question donc si une partie de
la classe qui est en distance yale et
l'autre en présentiel si ces termes
semble compliquée à digérer mais en gros
si une partie de la classe on va dire le
troisième qui est vacciné et l'autre qui
n'est pas vaccinée comment le prof va se
dédoubler pour faire court alors c'est
une très bonne question et les syndicats
ont rappelé que les profs ne pourrait
pas faire non plus complètement double
travail à moins d'avoir un système de
caméras dans les classes qui est déjà
installée mais ça c'est vraiment pour
certains établissements à ces
privilégiés mais sinon le prof ne peut
en effet pas faire cours en même temps
en distance yale et en présentiel du
coup ce qui va se passer c'est que comme
quand un enfant est malade il va donner
des exercices à faire il va s'assurer
que l'élève qui n'est pas la rattrapent
les cours qu'un de ses camarades lui
donne les fiches maintenant évidemment
les professeurs et des élèves peuvent
aussi beaucoup communiquer par par
messagerie par les systèmes d'école
direct se faire transmettre les devoirs
l'exercice et puis évidemment il va
rester en contact avec l'élève et à son
retour s'assurer que le travail qui nous
la donne et a été fait mais les
professeurs préviennent bien les
directeurs d'établissements et les
syndicats aussi ne peuvent pas à moins
d'avoir vraiment des systèmes
sophistiqués de caméras faire gomme en
même temps à des élèves qui n'ont pas il
faut pas là et à des élèves qui sont là
et cette continuité pédagogique est ce
qu'ils vont être accompagnés par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale et
c'est là où c'est à chaque prof chaque
classe chaque rectorat de se débrouiller
un petit peu comment ça marche c'est
plutôt à chacun de s'organiser après
voilà encore une fois les professeurs
les établissements sont quand même
maintenant à ses habitués puis on me
pose de beaucoup de systèmes modernes
aujourd'hui qui permettent de garder
contact avec l'élève donc chaque prof
chaque prof devra faire aussi en
fonction de sa matière évidemment vous
demandez pas les mêmes exercices en
fonction si vous êtes en matant français
en svt en musique moi j'étais avec un
prof de svt hier qui me disais bon bah
voilà les tp en laboratoire les travaux
pratiques on va pas ne pas les faire à
distance mais donc les professeurs
redoublent d'ingéniosité pour faire
court autrement et peuvent notamment
essayé d'utiliser toutes les tous les
outils qui sont à leur disposition et
des choses bien ciblée sur internet
des exercices voilà donc mais ça reste
quand même pas l'idéal et eux d'ailleurs
ils sont vraiment sur cette ligne là et
la plupart des professeurs qu'on a
interrogés dans le cadre de nos articles
sur la rentrée scolaire que vous pouvez
retrouver sur le site du figaro sont
quand même pas du tout favorable à ce
qu'ils appellent une éviction des élèves
non vaccinés des salles de cours pour
eux ça fait une différenciation très
problématique entre élèves vaccinés et
non vaccinés alors que ce n'est pas du
tout le rôle de l'école d'ailleurs ces
données on va dire sont transmises
acquis au chef d'établissement ou aux
professeurs de l'atlas par exemple est
ce que le professeur de chaque classe et
qu'il est vaccinés on va dire à
l'instant t dans sa classe alors si tout
va bien normalement non on n'a pas à
demander le statut vaccinal de du jeune
en revanche s'il ya un cas là il faudra
que la direction de l'établissement en
effet mène une enquête et là évidemment
sera au courant du statut vaccinal de
l'élève après l'idée ce n'est pas de
constituer des fichiers qui serait très
problématique notamment sur le plan des
la protection des personnels secret
médical etc mais en cas de contact qu'il
faudra quand même bien mené une enquête
et ce sera aux professeurs ou aux
directeurs d'établissements où des gens
de la rs&de des gens extérieurs est en
excellente question je sache je ne
saurais pas vous dire je pense qu'il
faut ça dépend probablement des
établissements des choses comme ça mais
on peut imaginer que ce sera confié
quand même à quelqu'un qui a l'habitude
de le faire enfin collectif de faire si
long qu'il va prendre l'habitude de le
faire malheureusement et qui prendra
soin que ces données soient pas
forcément révélée par tous parce que
c'est vrai que certains professeurs créé
que ça craignent que ça crée une sorte
d'ostracisme entre élèves vaccinés non
vaccinés et voilà on sait que les jeunes
aux lettres sont durs en dur entre eux
et ça c'est vrai que ça peut faire
partie des éléments qui peuvent être
difficiles tout ça c'est des choses
qu'on verra à la rentrée après le taux
de vaccination des adolescents là je
parle évidemment pas des enfants voient
la croissance n'est pas content il
aimait le taux de vaccination des jeunes
de 12 à 17 ans ne fait qu'augmenter même
s'il est encore inférieur au taux de
vaccination générale notamment parce
qu'il pouvait pas se faire vacciner
avant le mois de juin mais ça continue
d'augmenter et surtout de ministère a
prévu une importante campagne de
vaccination dont les locaux de certains
établissements dans les locaux d'autres
établissements ou dans des centres qui
seront placés à côté des établissements
scolaires salle ouvrira bientôt en
métropole donc la question ce sera est
ce que les élèves vont se faire vacciner
il ya toute la question se faire
vacciner sur leur lieu dans leurs
collègues de leur lycée où ce sera juste
une campagne d'information alors dans
certains établissements ils pourront se
faire vacciner y aura des centres de
vaccination éphémère qui seront mises en
place ou n'en sait pas encore beaucoup
plus sain il faudra attendre vraiment le
la rentrée passe un petit peu et que ces
centres de vaccination s'installe on
aura évidemment voir ça en reportage
pour le figaro mais dans certains
établissements il y aura vraiment des
centres dédiés à la vaccination des
12-17 ans
et tout le rôle des établissements
scolaires va être vraiment
particulièrement important parce que
leur rôle n'est évidemment pas d'obliger
parce que c'est pas obligatoire mais
pour eux il sera question pour les
directeurs d'établissements notamment
d'inciter les élèves de répondre à leurs
questions de leur expliquer pour les
régler leurs conseillers la vaccination
parce que la vaccination reste quand
même aujourd'hui la meilleure arme pour
lutter contre ce virus avec les gestes
barrière avec tout ce qu'on connaît
depuis un an et demi et est ce que vous
a évoqué tout à l'heure la couverture
vaccinale des 12-17 ans est-ce qu'on est
ce qu'on est ce qu'on la connaît celle
des professeurs alors celle des
professeurs on n'a pas de chiffres santé
publique comme on peut avoir sur
certaines tranches d'âge ou d'autres
choses de ce genre en revanche le
ministère a révélé un sondage qu'il a
mené qui a fait mener par l'institut
ipsos du 10 au 16 ou par internet un
sondage assez intéressant même s'il ne
porte que sur 500 professeurs donc on
peut pas comparer ça à des données de
santé publique mais ça reste pas moins
pas moins intéressant donc ce sondage
établissait que 78 % des professeurs qui
avaient été interrogés étaient
entièrement vacciner et 87% avait déjà
une dose en plus de ces deux chiffres là
on peut noter type 2 89% qui déclarait
que soit il avait une dose soit de doses
soit il allait prendre rendez-vous il
avait pris rendez vous en tout cas une
comtesse verbe est né il ya moins d'un
enseignant sur dix aujourd'hui qui a
déclaré c'est du déclaratif à pompey ne
pas se faire vacciner et est ce que le
ministère a donné des des consignes on
va dire donc aux directeurs
d'établissement ou aux professeurs de
faire de véhicules et on va dire de
prêcher la bonne parole pour les vaccins
alors là il ya une vraie différence à
faire entre les professeurs et puis les
directeurs d'établissement moi j'étais
au téléphone avec un directeur
d'établissement en région parisienne
derrière toi qui me disait que lui en
tant que représentant de l'état bien sûr
il portait la parole de l'état la parole
de l'état étant l'incitation à la
vaccination il la porte en revanche ils
disent eh bien nous on va pas pister les
élèves et leurs familles un par un on va
pas les obliger on va pas leur mettre la
pression c'est d'incitation c'est des
explications mais c'est pas de
l'obligation pour les professeurs en
revanche c'est différent
ils veulent pas forcément facile car
c'est ken un sujet très intimes est un
sujet qui n'est pas vraiment beaucoup de
familles ils ne veulent pas se mettre
devant même pas aller contre la liberté
de choix des familles l'association des
parents d'élèves l'apel me disais aussi
que voilà leur but qu'ils étaient
attachés au respect du choix des
familles et le but n'était pas d'entrer
dans les familles et ils d'obliger les
enfants les jeunes naceur vacciner
d'ailleurs à ce propos je précise
quelque chose peut-être les parents se
demande puisque aujourd'hui ils vont
emmener leurs enfants à l'école dans les
prochaines semaines peut-être y aura des
réunions parents profs etc ils n'auront
pas besoin de passes sanitaires pour
entrer dans l'établissement puisqu'il
n'y a pas de passe à lithaire en milieu
scolaire donc les parents pourront
emmener leurs enfants en classe je pense
notamment aux petits aux maternelles y
aura pas de problème après il faudra
quand même évidemment porté son masque
et faire attention aux gestes barrière a
pas toucher etc
mais les parents pour emmener leurs
enfants à l'intérieur de l'établissement
si c'est ça doit être le cas
si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
toujours en direct sur lefigaro.fr et
également sur la page youtube du figaro
la page figaro live bonjour christian
léon toussaint qui nous dit bonjour sur
le chat du figaro.fr vous êtes un
habitué merci de nous suivre encore en
direct nous allons retrouver tout de
suite sur le terrain mode canine cheval
qui est journaliste au figaro étudiant
et qui se trouve devant un ensemble
d'école primaire du xviie arrondissement
mode c'est à vous
l'agression commencer les masques enfin
parce que ce n'est plus une
préoccupation c'est plutôt il tombe
plutôt heureux pour la plupart sont tous
les parents de pouvoir en lui masque
devant l'école pourtant parents me dire
qu'en fait c'était sympa pour eux de
pouvoir voir les autres parents de pas
avoir les professeurs sans masque celle
d'un côté plus convivial
j'avais l'impression du coup de se
rapprocher d'eux et 10 pour les enfants
c'est presque devenu un accessoire de
mode il y avait une petite il expliqué
tout est alors pourquoi est elle avait
coordonné son masque avec sa tenue en
fait c'est tellement une obligation
aujourd'hui ils sont obligés d'intégrer
dans leur quotidien et donc aussi dans
leurs choix vestimentaires
merci mode on voit bien que les masques
sont au coeur de toutes les
préoccupations en cette rentrée en tout
cas sur le terrain aude est ce qu'on
peut refaire un point sur les masses
justement pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
et qui ont peut-être loupé votre
première son successeur seulement donc
pas de masque en dessous de 6 ans mais
en revanche à partir du cp jusqu'à la
fin du système scolaire obligation de
porter le masque en intérieur et en
extérieur ça dépend de des décisions
préfectorales locale sur le sujet donc
si le préfet de votre territoire a
décidé qu'il fallait porter le masque en
extérieur dont le porte en cours de
récréation à l'extérieur etc s'il n'y a
pas d'obligation on ne le portent pas et
c'est vrai que tous les gens qu'on
rencontre sont habitués comme disait
mode tout le monde est habitué
maintenant au port du masque qui couvre
bien le nez la bouche tout le monde a
commencé un peu avoir choisi est ce
qu'ils préféraient ni masque en tissu
ffp2 grand public enfin voila mais ça
n'empêche que ça reste quand même une
importante contraintes notamment dans
certains cours je pense notamment aux
cours de langues ou la prononciation est
très importante des cours où les
professeurs s'exprime beaucoup c'est
vrai que voilà ça reste une contrainte
que tout le monde espère pouvoir lever
un jour ou l'autre mais maintenant le
masque ça fait partie vous moi partout
des des contraintes qu'on a complètement
faussé complètement approprié on n'a pas
encore non plus de recul sur
les difficultés peut-être pour apprendre
à lire ou à écrire en cp pour ces élèves
de six ans qui suivent un professeur
masqué parce qu'on est ce qu'on a des
études sur le sujet alors fait de
réaliser wee cc c'est vrai que c'est une
vraie question il publiera des études
qui montreront tout ça ce qu'on peut
recommander par exemple pour les
instituteurs qui va ainsi tout risque
qui apprennent à lire aux enfants c'est
porter un masque et transparent qui
permet quand même vraiment par exemple
de voir les mouvements de la bouche des
choses comme ça donc ça c'est par
exemple une bonne initiative à mettre en
place quand on est comme ça sur
l'apprentissage de la lecture qui est
l'être quand même particulièrement
compliqué alors si vous nous rejoignez
nous sommes en direct pour détailler en
direct avec vous ce nouveau protocole
sanitaire qui rentre en vigueur
aujourd'hui dans les classes ryad bekir
qui est à la réalisation de cela il va
vous remonterez tout de suite donc la
communication faite par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale le ministère de
jean michel blanquer donc c'est cette
c'est une page on va dire qu'ils qui
donne les différents scénarios on va
dire et les différents protocoles en cas
s'applique à ces différents scénarios
donc nous sommes nous situé dans la
deuxième colonne donc la colonne jaune
alors vous voyez que c'est un petit peu
denses
pour ne pas dire illisible aude est-ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent les principaux on va
dire les principaux points à retenir de
ce protocole 2 qui entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui donc la règle du protocole
de ces le présentiel un mot qu'on adore
pas mais voilà qu'on utilise c'était
pratique le présentiel et ce sera la
règle est vraiment l'existentiel ne sera
que l'exception en fonction de
contamination cas contacts etc le port
du masque toujours en intérieur et
parfois en extérieur si la situation
locale oblige mais ne sera pas la
majorité
toujours évidemment beaucoup de gestes
barrières leur ont parlé du masque mais
aussi et à l'aération des salles de
lavage de mains évidemment le respect de
la dispensation sociale quand c'est
possible la limitation du brassage des
élèves et certaines mesures spécifiques
notamment en eps
on peut maintenant faire du sport en
extérieur évidemment bon en intérieur
aussi mais en évitant certains sports
notamment les sports de contact est-ce
que ce protocole donc de stade 2 est
vouée à durer toute l'année scolaire ou
est-ce que évoluer en fonction de la
crise sanitaire alors jean michel
branquart a bien dit que voilà nos deux
protocoles n'était n'était pas figé
complètement figé il peut être évolutif
si la situation s'améliore peut-être
qu'on passera en niveau 1 qui a dit
fication en cuir peut-être qu'on devra
passer au niveau 3 ou plus et aussi ce
qui est important de comprendre c'est
que les là pour l'instant le protocole
niveau 2 a été instauré pour toute la
métropole mais on peut être amené à
évoluer aussi en fonction des
territoires si demain après-demain dans
dix jours un territoire commence à être
en situation particulièrement difficile
on pourra avoir des indicateurs qui
montreront qu'il est temps de passer à
un niveau plus élevé et dans ces cas là
il y aura des différences de niveaux
alors vous venez d'évoquer la métropole
mais ce qu'on peu cheap on peut
peut-être faire un point pour pour ceux
qui habitent du coup dans les dents les
dom tom en france qu'est ce qui se passe
pour aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
également la rentrée paul alors on ne se
remet revoyez les situations sont très
contrastées déjà en outre-mer même en
manière j'ai de même manière générale
tous les ans ou tous on n'a pas la même
date de rentrée par exemple la réunion
est rentré le 17 août où le 16 août
dernier
ça se passe plutôt bien d'après d'après
les mots qu'on a de là-bas il ya
quelques classes fermées mais ça se
passe plutôt bien en revanche en
polynésie française la situation est
très compliquée et toutes les classes
ont dû fermer dès le 23 ou très vite
après la rentrée et ensuite aujourd'hui
devaient faire leur rentrée comme les
petits métropolitain tous les tous les
élèves scolarisés aux antilles les
élèves scolarisés en guyane etc il va ce
sera pas le cas puisque le ministère les
autorités ont décidé que la rentrée
serait décalée au moins 13 septembre en
guadeloupe en martinique à saint martin
et saint barthélémy et dans certaines
zones rouges de guyane notamment autour
de cayenne kourou et c'est donc on voit
vraiment des situations très très
contrastées pendant sa conférence de
presse de rentrée jean michel blanquer a
été interrogé sur est ce qu'il aurait
pas fallu reporter la rentrée aussi en
métropole et il a répondu fermement non
en disant c'est vraiment une solution de
dernier recours la situation est très
difficile notamment aux antilles ce qui
a obligé les autorités à faire ce choix
qui est quand même difficile mais tant
qu'on peut éviter ce choix jean-michel
bancaire est vraiment un fervent
partisan de l'école ouverte le plus
possible et vous avez vu sur les images
juste avant qui définit deux ans nous
nous c'est la rentrée des professeurs la
rentrée hier des professeurs c'était des
images donc de la fp donc c'est pour ça
que les classes sont vides les
professeurs ont travaillé sur les
programmes et les protocoles justement
hilaire tous ensemble alors christian
léon toussaint qui nous parle dans le
chat du figaro.fr merci à lui et qui
nous pose une question je pense pas que
ce soit l'objet de ce live mais je vais
la lire tout de même actualité en aude
affiche ces derniers mois est ce que les
enfants afghans ils iront à l'école
française c'est une question que l'on
posera peut-être à un autre
interlocuteur à notre expert ce n'est
donc pas l'objet de ce live en revanche
vous avez rebondit donc sur les masques
en nous donnant donc votre avis que si
on est on tout ça que je partage une
matière enseignée avec passion ne pose
pas de problème avec un professeur
masqué qui sait parfaitement l'exprimer
en présentiel alors ski je rebondis
cette réflexion c'est que j'ai
rencontrés hier un professeur et
pousseurs du théâtre qui le disaient
évidemment c'est particulièrement public
et avec le masque mais en revanche les
élèves apprennent à développer d'autres
choses tout ce qui est communication non
verbale c'est à dire qu'ils se rendent
compte que comme vraiment tous leurs
expressions leur visage est complètement
en tout cas chez masqué eh bien il faut
qu'ils apprennent à se faire comprendre
et notamment en théâtre ou est vraiment
important de faire passer les émotions
et autrement notamment par la
communication non verbale par les
oreilles la domination physique par les
yeux évidemment par la posture par le
tour de la voix donc bon évidemment on
peut pas se réjouir que tout le monde
doivent être masquée mais ça développe
d'autres choses chez les élèves chez les
messieurs c'est ça c'est intéressant à
noter quand même alors on va retrouver
tout de suite sur le terrain pour une
dernière intervention avant la fin de ce
direct mode ken hicks balle qui est donc
devant l'ensemble fourcroy laugier dans
le xviie arrondissement de paris
oui alors particulièrement mais il ya un
dernier rituel avant de partir en classe
c'est la faute aux jets avec man un
panneau qui a utilisé par pas mal de
parents ici il a marqué premier jour de
ces faits avec la date et c'est pour
pouvoir se souvenir longtemps de cette
rentrée exceptionnelle et de pouvoir on
va la garder en mémoire ces bons moments
alors match parce que sur les photos ça
dépend de l'enfant et surtout du parent
qui a envie ou pas que son enfant se
protège mais en tout cas la bonne humeur
la bonne humeur fans on est quand même
là et on a envie de garder en tête ces
moments là
merci mode merci beaucoup d'avoir raté
avec nous en fil rouge dans ce direct
pour nous faire vivre on va dire sur le
terrain la rentrée de ces de ses enfants
et aussi la rentrée pour ses parents
d'élèves on l'a vu qu'ils devaient être
ému de voir leurs petits enfants rentrés
en classe de cp pour les pour la plupart
je vais lire la question de christian
héon toussaint qui continue sur le chat
figaro.fr avant 2 avant de de vous
quitter qui nous parlait de notamment du
plan d'investissement du du président
qui est à marseille effectivement
aujourd'hui qui continue sa tournée et
qui va visiter notamment une école tout
à l'heure et qui va dévoiler son plan
d'investissement pour marseille et
notamment l'école dans cette ville ce
sera à suivre notamment sur figaro live
son discours à partir de 16h45 sur
lefigaro.fr je vais dire au revoir et
merci à haute barrier ti merci d'avoir
été avec nous et d'avoir éclairé cette
nouvelle rentrée scolaire et ses
difficultés de compréhension de ce
protocole sanitaire on retrouve tous vos
papiers donc sur dans les pages société
du figaro papier mais également sur le
figaro.fr je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste en charge des questions
d'éducation au figaro et quant à moi je
vous retrouve bientôt sur figaro live
merci de nous avoir suivis et merci à
ryadh des pierres pour la réalisation de
ce direct à bientôt merci